hello my name is Schaefer I need a
limousine with a chauffeur right now for
the rest of the day there's none
available okay okay what are my options
a chauffeur with a rental car fine I
don't really have a choice I'll take it
great thanks goodbye
is this really what Emmanuel had in mind
when he called for a limo he probably
wanted a big Mercedes s-class an Audi a8
or a BMW 7-series but a Kia Optima sedan
well this is a nice alternative hello
hello mr. Schaefer what do you have here
it is a Kia Optima it's not what I
usually drive but I'm always up for a
surprise we're testing the optimist
plug-in hybrid version
it has an electric motor and a 2 liter
gasoline direct injection engine with
assistant performance of 151 kilowatts
it can accelerate to 100 kilometres an
hour and 9.4 seconds
fuel consumption is 1.6 liters per 100
kilometers
[Music]
like the Kia Optimas performance can't
quite keep up with the other cars a
chauffeur usually drives but it doesn't
have to but less power driving is
generally more relaxed you just slow
down and feel you've rested when you
reach your destination the Optima has a
distinctive appearance in the front it
has an active radiator grille that only
opens when necessary
[Music]
newly designed front and back bumpers
help reduce drag
[Music]
keya now offers to plug-in hybrids the
Nero and the Optima the batteries charge
at a regular power outlet and purely
electric mode the range is 54 kilometers
[Music]
our chauffeur says this is a pleasant
surprise he usually drives grander cars
but the Kia Optima really makes a good
impression it's well designed and very
high quality he can definitely recommend
it the plug-in hybrid is available in
two equipment levels even the basic
version includes a cruise control system
dual zone climate control a heated
steering wheel front seat heating and an
electronically adjustable driver's seat
with a memory function today we're
testing the top model with even more
features and comfort
yeah our backseat guest says back here
you have everything you need heat
seating a USB plug to charge your phone
and plenty of space it's really
remarkable his legs could be twice as
long it could be 2 meters 10 and still
have enough room it's very nice Vasek
one thing that sets the optima apart is
how very spacious it is all things
considered the Kia Optima definitely has
what it takes to be a limousine a
chauffeur my drive it can rival luxury
class cars even if it does lack some
small features and the quality of the
materials is not on a par with that of
other cars but then it does cost a lot
less and Germany the Optima plug-in
Hybrid lists at 37 and a half thousand
euros that's after subtracting the three
thousand euro subsidy for eco-friendly
electric and hybrid cars at first he was
a bit skeptical when they offered him
this alternative but he's convinced the
Kia Optima is a good alternative it has
performed very well and looks good the
interior is incredibly roomy and as a
hybrid it is even doing a little to
protect the environment what more could
you want
[Music]